[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stick
despite oops
ah I'm going to go to the next part I
know that it uses the at some point it
uses language that it is unpalatable but
I'm putting the discussions of people
this is how they speak page one five to
four now this part and I will invite the
court to go through it at some point
cause I won't read off without started
lying ninety three I mean ninety-two
it's Leonard McCarthy says but I will
call you when I'm up there again at this
stage my flight is on Thursday I did
what you said I shoot I must say
you did the right thing right there says
Mililani and then at McArthur up until
Friday the the then I received a strong
memorandum to say charge and charge now
Berlin says Friday yeah I know this
Friday the team says we have been
[ __ ] around with this thing and we
are allowing Algeria considerations to
play in and it will become an
impossibility later we must take action
and deal with it and finish and Clarke
as Jackie çelebi said but that is
another story
milord and milady that's that bit it one
of the key things that demonstrate that
Leonard McAfee was unlawfully discussing
charging with somebody else who's not in
the NP but there's another thing it
tells us it tells us what he thought of
the advice that I said he was given
charge charge now himself just like hey
is this deals with the timing of the
timing of the charges yeah that's the
time it it's the timing the deals with
the time and and and I will argue at the
end is that day there's no aspect of
prosecution that must be decided with a
politician no matter how unimportant
with
I'm gonna go when they talk about the
indictment page one five to eight other
upcoming who you serve with these
comments that's why I don't read them
because they you know we do with the
document alcohol absolutely the reason I
remember can connect let me explain this
document
I'm not a spy but I think I understand
how this works is that when you have
transcripts like this of people who've
been recorded what you then on the side
because it forms no intelligence until
it's really processed in in their own
cycle and what you have on the side
maybe a comment about speculation about
what they think and the reason I'm not
reading it to the court that much is
because I do not want to burden this
court with what I think I'll an
intelligence operative or information
analyst was writing thinking what he was
thinking or what she was them
so McCarthy says and by them time that
decided he wants to go home and the kid
wants to start his leave because his
mother at the end of her life and he
wanted the last holiday with her and one
of the ploy were on leave and turn off
his on leave and I said drafting with
one advocate and we probably finished
half of it now Salman must look at it
and trend off said he wants it so
important he would like to see it before
it goes in before he must argue the
campaign which is fair so we will prove
he was not involved they were talking
about him but I'm reading this portion
because it talks about the the
indictment
is this the endowment so is it then it
says can I get a draft can you deliver a
draft at my place where are you now in
Jobbik okay I will back then that says I
thought you said they are touching your
leave and you will be there yeah but
it's part of my leave I was actually
coming to Cape Town to see you but no no
it's fine then that says I will get I'll
rather come myself I don't want to take
chances no because I will get there late
tonight then that says no I'll wait for
you and call me when you are here or I
will see you fasting in the morning or
you come to me I don't know but I don't
want intermediaries here but Ilana says
okay you're right you're absolutely
right yeah you know Zuma will say we are
conspiring against him
can I ask in the script and the script
has not changed yet it's a question I'm
making one point here that I said we
must connect the right dots not the
wrong ones we must connect the right
dots above this pattern that this is
being discussed
whatever it is unlawfully with someone
who has no business in the prosecution
of mr. Zuma or anybody
but are the next pages of this that I
will invite the court to go through and
I want to summarize them because we will
be here the whole week if I do it's a
lot of terrible things people are saying
is that they will demonstrate to you
that a president was involved in their
discussions a minister was involved in
their discussions that the timing of the
prosecution had nothing to do with
prosecutorial functions that the timing
as you will see if you read the parts I
have not read is that precisely what the
NPA has been told time and again by
those who care to tell it they do not
have and they are constitutionally
prohibited from taking instructions
about aspects of prosecutions and doing
their work so why is this important why
is all of this important it's important
as I will get to the cases now because
as we read these cases that deal with
the permanent state it's a matter we've
debated slightly that all a delay on its
own and time is not enough for you to
get a permanent state there must be
extraordinary circumstances that exist I
want to invite this court to agree with
me that
when an organ of state as powerful as
the NPA now in the future or in the past
because it will be asked one day when
they discuss with political players
about when you must be arrested and how
you must be prejudiced by that and they
discuss it with people who have nothing
to do with prosecution our courts which
are the custodians of constitutionalism
must not tolerate it simply because we
believe we're dealing with a suspect who
may have committed what we don't like
it's the point I am making the point
about this is this is that the pattern
of behavior is what distinguishes this
almost twenty-year-old case from the
other cases some of which a stay was
granted after a delay of three years
like mr. Phillips and others but maybe
let me just go and I persist with the
arguments we make there and those
decisions I also want to submit to this
court that the court must go to those
parts of our heads of arguments when we
deal with criticism by our courts of the
conduct of the NPA in this matter so let
me just try an understandable at this
point because I think it's important so
I'm suggesting that once we find that
there was this discussion we shouldn't
look at the integrity of the
investigation here that doesn't retain
that in any way
no there is no aspect that I'm inviting
the court not to look at me that's the
first so we still have to interrogate
today in capital yes and consider but
here is the point I'm trying to make I
am saying in your attempts to read and
find how serious corruption is and all
the points you must look at you are the
custodians of how organs of state must
act and whatever you find with all of
those things how serious corruption is
how insignificant the delay is what is
important and I find that we submit is
extraordinary is what this court says
about those who hold power of the state
to prosecute others when they tell lies
or when they abuse or when they connive
with people who are outside the state
and it is the courts function to
determine whether all the factors milord
you say you may want to consider can
ever justify an organ of state
grunting upon itself grunting itself
power to act as it wish and
unconstitutionally and unlawfully as we
support
well we have set out those facts in
Malad I don't want to I have gone
through what we call in our heads the
despite age the reason I have not read
all of it is exactly as I said I've
concentrated on those parts that really
really demonstrate to you that in
discussion about an accused an
instruction was being taken from
politicians and this court must tell us
how we could use in a National Director
of prosecutions taking instructions from
an outsider and Lincoln whatever they
want to do to political outcomes I know
that our Leonard friends like say no but
harms dealt with that motive issue a
long time ago we're not suggesting we're
not dealing with motive we're not
dealing with that aspect we're dealing
with the fact that an organ of state
acted unconstitutionally violated its
own policies violated the act from which
it derives its power and lastly violated
the Constitution and this court must
tell us if when it balances it with
other things that unconstitutional
conduct can be condoned those parts we
insist with them they are there I want
to go to the to invite this court
because the what I'm saying here is not
just the story that mr. Zuma has told or
is telling I invite this part without
reading this affidavit of mr. Hoffman
because that is the MPM as the off mayor
wrote that as the NPA condemning how
they had behaved I'm inviting this court
again
to read mr. Michelle's statement itself
how the NPA had himself this is the MTA
described their own conduct the fact
that those whose come later for
different motives don't like what he
said the fact that colleagues in the
media insurgent at the bar call it what
they call it the fact of the matter is
the institution itself at different
times those who have a conscience in it
have described their conduct as bad
indefensible and unlawful themselves
it's not asked on them I will not going
to be constrained in some of these
criticisms why by the findings of the
essay for instance in the in mister of
meristem shares because they've made fit
various findings in these particular
issues and I don't think we can find
otherwise unless say something that you
convince us otherwise if they have found
in a particular manner well
it's a famous argument from Arlen
offenses were or the SCA has said ABCD
ignores mayor the SCA have said ABCD let
me tell it this melody that affidavit of
mr. off man remains something the s the
NPA stated on oath the comments of the
judges about his conduct and we know he
is still there he's still there he's
still around and he has just been
promoted he acted well so he's a man of
integrity he's there his affidavit has
not been found to be a lie he has not
written an affidavit countering that I
think the comments that I saw in the
cases about it
our Leonard friends pick they choose
what it is that they think he is right
by saying and where they think he is
wrong we say this court must consider an
affidavit filed by the NPA in a matter
on oath before it and we do not have an
affidavit disputing that from this day
off now this day off mayor that's his
affidavit we say it's consistent with
the statement of mr. steamship look at
the decision of the ACA
[Music]
two three zero and it concludes in
paragraph 75 of that judgment mr. mr.
Hoffman was in came on including the
decision to prosecute mr. Giamatti mr.
McCarthy we sorted his cell as untreated
statement made on behalf of the employee
in after day between other litigation
that machine has made the decision to
prosecute this was done not first on you
that this court in Douma I decided on
the evidence place before it that mr.
Sherr taking decision to prosecute mr.
Zimmer and then it goes on under
criticism of that I think if I am a suit
my sister correctly is we cannot ignore
the findings of the Supreme Court of
Appeal regarding that kind of a yeah so
I think it is there a way that we should
ignore this what would then be your
situation regarding the criticisms the
essay was never faced with the question
you are faced with today
today the essay is also spoken about the
timing
they say the motive is still relevant
prosecution is not a perfect but if you
go further than that if we actually look
at a missing share statement in his own
statement he makes a point that he could
find nothing wrong with their will they
investigated prosecution team in other
words there was nothing wrong with it
with the investigation itself he makes
that point he makes it clear is that
they would fast that nice can I start
with your question complete
they were not faced with the question
you must determine they made comments
they did not say that that affidavit I
do not believe that that affidavit must
be ignored what is said by the this
organization on earth must be ignored
because the the SCA had comments about
mr. Hoffner and what he will say it
remains what and they described their
conduct on oath in court the second
thing is this and I invite you to read
more in the spy tapes because you will
find members of the NPA discussing what
to hide from a court so it's not it's
not it's not as something I'm I'm taking
from knowing and I'm saying one of the
issues you will have to deal with is it
really not a smoking gun that can be
cleared by the trial court which at
issue that issue up on top of a with the
tapes well this is the answer I gave in
India is it depends on what what you are
dealing with what I've presented to you
is what I say are Extra Ordinary
violations of the Constitution and there
is nothing that can't be dealt with the
trial court but what I'm submitting to
you is that violations of the
Constitution in pursuit of even the
ugliest criminal we hate cannot be
condemned condoned and I'm saying it is
Extra Ordinary to violate a constitution
if you find if you find this is when I
will lose this case if you find and you
have to find this way to differ with me
is that all of the things that happen
the discussion with politicians and
South Africa when I want to charge a
fine if you find that it's not unlawful
when I'm prosecuting
to do what we say Leonard McCarthy and
when Alana Nova did is not against the
spirit and provisions of our
Constitution I must lose this case if
you find that NPA from today and going
forward in pursuit of someone who's
accused they can do what Leonard
McCarthy was doing they can take
instructions from the DA and the ANC and
everybody in order to time things to
suit political players you are free to
take that decision this court I must
lose this case if this Court does not
find that violation extraordinary and
I'm adding it because most of those
cases tell us how difficult this is I am
saying this court the three of you sit
here as probably the ultimate custodians
of the Constitution and I will gladly
lose the matter if a court tells me that
violations of the Constitution of this
nature unjustified not in terms of
sections substances the decidua tells us
how we can violate them if it's allowed
it's just done I will gladly accept that
I'm wrong but I am saying it is
extraordinary that people can violate a
Constitution the way they want because
they are pursuing someone with dislike
and they're pursuing someone they
suspect
so it can be decided my lord in the
trial court but the court will have to
go through what I'm submitting now
disagree with me on what I've just told
you now and I will gladly accept your
reading then we deal with the cases I
promise my elephants are banana tree so
that one Russian I invite the court to
look at all of the findings by judging
smog there is no suggestion that judging
semen was wrong in stating the things I
have stated and he wasn't even he hadn't
read my soul rest in peace he hadn't
even read the spy tapes even then in
2006 he complained bitterly about the
conduct of the NPA yes I know such an
that the bar doesn't like Nicholson
saying people say it was an I'm saying
I'm inviting this court read what he
says in relation to what you must find
you are determining what is before you
because it has never been before anybody
the questions you are dealing with have
never been before any court and you are
free to determinate the way you wish
without different with the constant
immediacy
now what are the cases that should guide
you and what do they say
Matata
let me start just briefly with the boss
moccasin and let me tell you what it was
about you without taking your time this
is in 2010 it's a constitutional court
matter in this case mr. bottner
instituted a private prosecution versus
its messes complaining but when she was
13 and 37 years had passed she was raped
or sexually abused by a master else a
family friend
I think it said it had been 39 years and
on 21 December she instituted a private
prosecution she first appeared on the 20
on the 5th of February 2008 just ya
think
well in less than a year then it was
remanded to 17 June 2008 the same year
then before it was held
he brought a permanent scale application
and this is there are two questions that
are important in this case for you to
determine because they raise issues
about which we can get criticized in
this matter he says after two three
years all the evidence is gone
this was 37 39 years ago now he is
talking about the time when the offense
was committed not when the prosecution
started so basically he is complaining
and he loses this case because he is
complaining that there has been a delay
by the stage
of some two years or three years because
eventually it was set down into October
20 2009 he also complained that the
offense occurred a long time ago as if
that makes any difference
in terms of its nature but of course he
was criticized because he he talks about
the time of his offense not the time
when the NPA started I mean when the
prosecution started his case and he
loses of course because the court says
he had to detain the trial prejudice
that he he complained about he said
people had died the evidence was no
longer they couldn't find his diary
where he was on the day and so how
different a week this case well I have
it set to this Court first of all you
have to determine how long this has been
secondly you have to determine the fact
that we've asked for documents we don't
have them we don't have a full set up to
today you have to determine the fact
that can we ever have a fair trial after
such a lapse of time in a matter of this
nature and the type of evidence to be
learned in a matter of this nature and
lastly because all of these cases tell
you is this is extraordinary you've got
to tell us much more I don't want to
harp on the point there is something
extraordinary about constitutional
violation I think so our case mr.
Zoomers case is distinguishable from
those cases for a number of reasons the
other one that our Leonard Francis and
Remis it's a famous case because judges
make telling points was the Sanderson
case and I know why our Leonard friends
like this case because it's part of the
theory about mr zuma mr zuma is they say
he is because of the deletion and the
sunderson case at paragraph 33 adding
talks about an accused who is the
primary agent of the delay cannot come
to Horton and complain that there has
been a delay
it's like someone pending the court and
saying I'm coming for the feminine state
because the court is not available and
the court was right in cases where the
courts have said this they were right
but I have said in our case you cannot
compare it with these cases if you look
at the facts you look at what has
happened you look at the violations you
look at who caused which delays and
there were many postponements in that
case I was going to read its passages
but I don't have to or Leonard friends
there is a case as well
it's the Fraser case that I referred to
because we we allow us sometimes we pick
cases that say what we want to say but I
think it's important to state all of
these cases including the ones that are
not with us this was a civil case for a
for a start
Fraser case unlike what we are dealing
with here the appellant was an awaiting
trial prisoner who had been indicted on
several counts related to racketeering
and money Lerner was a different matter
altogether and he said he was charged in
terms of poker so a provisional
restraint under Section 26 of poker was
obtained against him against his
interest in a close cooperation
his other properties so that's the
nature of that case but what does he do
this is the man they accused later as I
will say that he he was he participated
in wrongdoing that led to the delay
because basically Absa gets involved in
this matter because it was one of
phrases concurrent creditors who had
obtained the default judgment against
him and they sought to intervene right
they lost but then their case was
dismissed and then the SA the SCA
abscess appeal was upheld Fraser
opposed to Concord to appeal against the
essay on the ground that its decision
will result in unreasonable delay and of
course he lost and he should have lost
because as they said there he had been
involved himself in trying to concern
his property his assets so all of this
case I invite this court to go to the
state to the Phillips case versus the
DPP because in that one it was granted
I invite this court without wasting its
time to go to the funnier than case and
look at it I invite them to invite you
to read the others and see that the
golden thread that runs through them is
that while these courts tell us that
this is an extraordinary remedy they
tell us that when the fairness of the
trial in terms of section 35 3 D has
been severely compromised or affected
you can't say you will not grant if that
is demonstrated the others tell us as
your ladyship was saying the delay on
its own is not enough
anything else and they tell us that of
course because it's extraordinary what
exceptional circumstances exist I know
that exceptional sounds like something
spectacular must happen I'm inviting
this court to look at whether if they
find as I said an organ of state acting
unconstitutionally acting unlawfully in
pursuit of a citizen is not spectacular
in a more earthly modern democracy in a
constitutional state I'm inviting this
court to tell me and us that it's not
spectacular to act that way and the
submission I am making is that even if
we are weak on every point
even if Mr Zuma postponed all the metals
in serve in the past 15 years because he
is a Stalinist it is exceptional it is
exceptional that constitutional
violations happen by an organ of state
whose power is one of the most serious
because it can limit our liberties those
are the cases I invite this court to
look at and those are the cases on the
basis of which the issues I have raised
my lord and my ladies is that you will
find that when you read some of the
things I have not read in the spy tapes
and the violations that I put before you
when you look at whether or not even if
Mr Zuma may have contributed to some
delay by going to court because we told
that even both approaching a court by
him is a delay doing the right thing not
discussing
case with a politician going to court
making representation he's responsible
you will find no occasion in these 5,000
pages before you when the postponement
was because of him yes he may have
wanted to make representations but that
is an exercise of his right as a
litigant where he feels that his rights
were violated those if you find against
us on all of the issues about the delay
and if you think they must be juxtaposed
with everything else I want to invite
you to look at those cases and tell us
and make a decision that the violations
which are common cause of the supreme
law of the land do not constitute
exceptional circumstances I am inviting
this court to write any judgment I'm not
desperate to win this case I'm desperate
to hear how organs of state and myself
and everyone must behave between now at
the future about the Constitution I want
to hear this court tell me that acting
unconstitutionally is not exceptional
those are the issues we say even if we
are wrong which we dispute because they
delay the social stigma when I say in
the head Mr Zuma is synonymous with
corruption now is something we right as
I said we have to think back to that
social stigma whether we would like it
unto ourselves a social stigma you carry
as a family man for being accused and
that stigma I'm inviting you to look at
it in a constitutional democracy as acts
as an exceptional occurrence that
violates the values that we call
on that point can I ask this question
mr. Cattani
as I understand the argument and the
papers that stigma started way back 2000
or 2003 and it's carrying on this
application does not go into the merits
of the case if we were to grant it it
leaves that stigma standing when will it
ever be cleared or will it ever be
cleared because I think it's on record
on several occasions that Mr Zuma said
he wanted to clear his name so in a
balancing act
how are we to how will will that ever
happen in three parts because the
question you ask is why doesn't he go to
court a lot of people think I should
just walk Mr Zuma to Horsham important
prison always will because no I'm saying
that's the that's my introduction to
that you've started it in their honor
wrong between you saying rights why
doesn't he just goes not vote well and I
don't want it to be misunderstood I'm
trained how to balance all of those
factors now balance at this one we are
still asking to consider that any
accused person whether you may